hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sushi dough now this is a
game that came out of the game jolt Game
Jam about me Jack and pewds so this one
is actually really fun because I played
it and it's it's lovely lovely relaxing
little game about fishing in a little
itty bitty boat and use just an
itty-bitty kitty but things get really
interesting once you actually get sushi
yarn make also see trying Oh wicked
whoop and that's how you play the game
that's pretty much all let's do it and
like that's really awesome like this
game is so simplistic and yet it's like
really really I don't know it's got that
addictive quality this game actually won
second place in the whole thing so you
can see that it's actually well done I
mean it's really amazing see what these
guys can do in such a short amount of
time they only had like I don't know if
this might be the post jam edition of
the game but it's so good it's so oh
it's got that element that's hard to
describe about some games the simplicity
of it and like the simplicity of like
you're obviously a little fishing game
but obviously it's a little more than
that and if I could just get some damn
fishes without ruining okay here we go I
didn't mean to put
I know it's kind of like it's gotta get
a little bit of a one finger death punch
element to it so it's gone I got that
and I mean obviously it's Japanese
inspired it's kind of a little kitty
that you're playing us but there's more
to it than that that's like more
interesting intricate details about it
and as you increase your weight limit
and get more of the shoosh yeah
oh there's a shark damn it I keep
forgetting that I can't put it down oh I
don't write oh good god like demonic
floating cat here I mean I know I'm
committing some sort of eco-terrorism
with just how many fish I'm pulling out
of this and obviously I'm not even
eating the sushi that I'm making out of
it so there's kind of a bit of an
ethical problem there but I don't really
care because I'm having a blast so I can
just just a little bit of just a little
bit just a little bit whoa that's a new
one just a little bit I wonder I wonder
like the what the limit of the oh [ __ ] I
keep pissing it down but when I don't
need to do that [ __ ] no I soccer oh I
can do better than that
come on I get way way way better than
that
way way way better than that maybe you
come here you come here you damn it yeah
come on I know I can do better than this
I will make sushi glory of whatever
country I'm from I'm not exactly
also the music is really addictive like
I love the music I love everything about
this game I can obviously see why I won
second place and I want you all to try
to beat my high score here because
that's the whole point of why this game
damn happened like a whole theme of this
game damn if you couldn't tell was high
score I don't know if I ever mentioned
that before it's ready to be sliced and
diced yes he's like no one's even eating
who would come to a sushi house in the
middle of an ocean just floating in the
middle of nowhere so I mean you gotta
admit that sushi cats kind of greedy
here I mean he seems cool and all but to
be honest I don't know if I want to be a
friend I want to be associated I mean
then again there are ills with chains on
them I mean their chains do hang low
they may wobble to and fro but I have no
recollection of a I know I know
yram it did Chris didn't know way to rim
it increased
come on you lose damn bastard I just
can't press the down button because it's
like a habit
it really is strict on the amount of
lives in the goddammit there's a lot to
focus on when you're going at it
Oh little questionable to be making
sushi out of sharks Wow
yes it's time what
can't miss a single one here there we go
I mean even that shirt doesn't really
make a lot of sushi I mean where am I
getting all the other ingredients for
these sushis cuz you gotta imagine
there's like cucumber avocado crap going
on here those are a lot of really clever
and colorful rolls but I'm not too sure
about that
in case you didn't notice I love sushi
like I absolutely adore sushi but none
that way don't make it weird it's not
like I have a relationship with sushi or
anything I'm not like that guy that
other relationship with his car or
whatever whoa I don't think I want to
eat that rainbow fish that seems like a
special unicorn
come on you [ __ ] oh man there's a lot
of fishing yes oh man it's so funny it's
so fun I don't even know why it's so fun
but it's really really fun look I always
appreciate these games that are
simplistic in a lot of ways but they're
so like it's not a game isn't bad
because it's simplistic a game is good
because it it's it's very good in it
like expressing one idea and if it can
do that really well then it doesn't need
to be over goodly complex like a game
like this can be really fun and
addicting like this would make a
phenomenal like phone game I really hope
the guy who made this does port this
over to like some other operating system
and makes you know Bank often because
this is really really well done and
really elegant move it it's got a kitty
loves kitties kinda uh probably uh oh
crap oh man we're getting tied up on
here I don't know if that's an apt
description of what's going on here tied
up on here the sushis getting tied up on
here wait I'll remit did Chris yeah sure
did didn't it
alright on a big first sketch big for a
sketch big fries get come on oh come on
come on grab my pole grab my pay
Whiteman bite and bite mitt damn it god
damn it fine yeah anything really the
bigger fish only come out once you've
gotten some bunch of gold-digging fish
here I mean they're digging their own
graves but I mean still I can call gold
diggers I'm shallow like that
Oh goddamn it
man I got a multitask on so many things
here not gold now go bruh not cool not
cool bruh
damn it how'd I miss that gimme gimme
yes please thank you thank you Oh God so
many things to think about poop come on
one more get you you yes I made it oh my
god boy that was close oh my god I did
it
holy crap I did it holy crap holy crap I
did it I did it I did it I did it oh man
that's so cool
oh man it's really hard because you do
have to shift lanes before you can
actually get to the ones that you want
to get to so you have to you have to
really plan it out when you're going
there and you don't have a lot of time
to plan it out oh boy oh boy oh boy okay
come on and troll crowd I wasn't looking
out Frick and frack crackalacka yeah you
can't get too many small ones are also
throw you up on everything else that's
going on there so you kind of want to
try to avoid the small ones try to get
the big ones I mean I'm just spitting
all this strategy out of my butt so I
don't really know anything that actually
is supposed to happen here all I know is
that I'm doing pretty good so far here
we go I will I know
go ahead
oh god this is not a good situation
oh okay man Serge Miller admitted their
answer ah yes
oh boy I'll remit the grist I know oh
man so stressful
shouldn't be the stressful games
shouldn't be the stressful but it really
is I want it I want to perform you know
I get a little bit that performance
anxiety and I you know I'm I vote my
bones they just lock up I can't really
do it my heart gets racing I gotta get
it good oh hey you guys ever get that
performance anxiety I'm not talking
about anything else I'm talking about
fishing and making sushi you ever get
yeah we get sushi anxiety there you guys
out there again
no I'm weird I don't know about that
really dicey really dicey really desi
Lacey and I sees Lacey and Lizzie I have
to be the sushi I have to be the sushi
cat oh man I just saw this little
expression on his face I think I saw it
before but didn't fully register what it
was he's so adorable in that he's
committing like mass murder of all these
fishy friends I mean he is a cat so I
guess that is his want in life but maybe
you should be more conservative I mean
now that I've become a full tree-hugging
hippie here
good thing I got lots of big ones here
not many small ones
yes okay what remitted Chris where's our
mission Chris I think actually the combo
gets bigger the more fish you have so
maybe like having smaller ones isn't it
oh god damn it I was not how the Frick
did that happen
I'm not that bad normally man my
performance are anxious my perform
anxiousness okay Elswick okay oh man my
biggest prime is gonna be the damn rocks
if I keep getting hitting by the rocks
I'm never gonna get anywhere in life I'm
never gonna do anything with my life he
could have been an engineer instead I'm
playing sushi gotta be in suji god what
a bunch of good decisions I made in life
how long till I pitter-patter all over
the place how long until I flip flap the
UM yams of my oh my god shut up market
Meyer Marga Meyer where's she shut up
concentrate on the goddamn game just
don't die from a goddamn rock oh come on
can I stop miss Oh Oh God own die
I'm a goddamn Rock it's all I ask
and Mason's are also delightful might I
say I really appreciate the fluidity and
the pixel art style is durable oh okay
here we go
ma'am I hope my wrist is getting tired
from spamming these arrow keys oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh oh those little ones
are gonna be the death of me wait those
little ones are gonna be the death of me
well I'm saying the rocks gonna be the
death of me because I'm such an idiot I
won't be able to avoid it
the one way I didn't want to freaking
die god dammit okay so anyway that is
sushi - sushi cat or whatever you want
to call it or no sushi cats a different
game I think I have no idea
that's sushi dough so thank you all so
much for watching I really hope you play
this one it's a lot of fun it is really
well crafted I loved it to death it's
charming it's adorable and there's a lot
to love about so thank you everybody so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done find this
game in the description down below let
me know if you beat my high-score and as
always I will see you in the next video
oh pretty cars okay duck shoot a batch
again